thank you very
much any questions or
comments
bribery
who's only1 no uh there was a personal
connection uh if you saw the credits
carefully there was General Sam
Cohen and uh I I met him several years
ago to Oxford and he had seen some of my
films and actually this film grew out of
another film that I was working on a
film on masculinities and uh for that
film my idea was to look at men in
different work situations and one of the
men Works settings that I chose was to
be a soldier so little did I know that
it was almost impossible to get into the
brish camp and when I found out that I I
wrote a letter to Sam who I had been
kind of involved in on a personal matter
I was actually doing him a little favor
and asked him you know how should I how
should I approach the British Embassy
for permission and the next thing I knew
was he had uh sent the strongest
recommendation and then they sort of
vetted my films and interviewed me and I
went to the British camp so she would
film to the Nepali officers and told
them what I wanted to do and then it was
SP sailing after that
yeah um K thank you for that that was
such a stunning um film in so many ways
I'm wondering what sort of reactions
you've received um from the soldiers
both the Nepali soldiers and the British
officers who've seen the film
well soldiers are not generally very
expressive pardon me they but I shoted
at the British Camp uh at the PO British
Camp as well as the British camp in
Katmandu and they all sort of nodded
their heads and applauded and apparently
it was shown at Sandhurst uh uh without
me knowing about it but apparently
thousand people applauded and so forth
and uh so I don't know I mean uh the the
very few comments I got was some of the
Nepali officers in pocra sort of turned
around and said you know these white
guys don't get it uh you know they like
really sympathetic to someone who might
be have a shuffle in the leg and so
forth and we know that they won't get in
so we sort of are brutal and honest and
and and take them out whereas the
British tend to be sentimental and let
them mour and so forth so this was the
only comment I on uh very strange but
after the first screening in Katmandu at
the Katmandu Mountain film
festival I I obviously had a bit of trp
addition because while you want to do
the film that you want to do you you
always have a feeling when you encounter
the persons who were somewhat involved
whether they think they've been betrayed
or they don't like it or they're not in
the film and to my surprise the British
Ambassador was said he was thrilled and
at the same time they were many nepales
who were very emotion said who were very
emotionally affected by it so it was a
strange uh kind of response and this
response has been going on through all
the very many
screenings so uh I don't know why but uh
you know maybe it got beyond the
polemics of there is a debate and it
kind of got the feeling of uh uh the
experience and the people who have a
have a part in it who have a stake in
this
maybe
yeah
fin in the final ironic scene I heard
some laugh laughter in the audience uh I
was not one of them I I don't think any
Nepali could uh laugh by that time I was
also Crying by that
time well I I think the people in the
audience someone might could comment on
that I mean I I don't know if it if
there's laughter but there's maybe uh
kind of awkward laughter maybe that that
would be my reading actually yeah is a
different
reaction yeah true true it is a
different reaction uh I think uh for
most nepalis it was actually
very uh emotionally affecting
and in the first couple of screenings I
had in
Amsterdam uh many people like the film
and thought that you know what's the
stakes in it you know everyone goes into
the army everyone is uh goes out for
some rigorous contest you know in work
and so forth so I I think film is very
malleable and ultimately it's the not
even ultimately initially and ultimately
it's really the encounter between who is
seeing and what is there and what is
there is you know is there's so many
elements there which are read
differently uh affected affect people
differently that's the only thing I can
say Kon thank you for that film I was
struck by your use of archival footage
and I wonder if you could reflect a
little bit on the material that you did
use and how you encountered it and what
your sort of experience on seeing it for
the first time was yeah this was I think
the biggest problem the challenge
because the gurka is a major Narrative
of Nepal as we all know and so how
to kind
of uh not do justice to that to the
history and at the same time the film I
wanted to make was not a kind of a BBC
kind of a historical uh narration driven
film uh expositional film so really the
answer was to find an archive of
material that would say uh that would
show uh what I did not want to say and
uh so finding finding it was a a
challenge and I had a good friend in the
UK who went to the two museums and we
had a long process of finding footage on
L reses sending it to me and then
looking at it to see what fits the bill
so it was uh the gurka museum in
Winchester and the Imperial War Museum
and some of the footage is from the
first world war yeah it's
incredible my reaction to laughter was
you laugh so you don't
cry s that was a very um strong movie I
think especially given the fact that
much of um our part of the world um
economics determine a lot of these and
and and this is going on um in terms of
exporting a lot of the youth from our
region you know for for economic
opportunities looking elsewhere the
Middle East definitely and of course for
Nepal I mean it it's had a long history
of of that through the goras and and now
of course the in the Middle East with
the construction and many other um labor
Bhutan is is is also treading along
similar path I wouldn't say it's exactly
the same it's it's um deliberate it's
also creating jobs and opportunities but
sometimes I
think Society I think is is divided you
know on the one hand I think you're
looking at Youth and and unemployment
and and somehow you feel like exporting
your youth for jobs and and and such
elsewhere could hopefully maybe resolve
some of the economic um problems at home
but for Bhutan it hasn't hit hard right
now now and and things are going
relatively I mean we have been fortunate
but in in the minds of some people they
think sending unskilled workers abroad
and then them sending back the money and
as is done in many parts of our part of
the world looking at that as a solution
I I think this is a message that I I
could could truly see and and is a path
that I wish that our countries you know
will will not tread on but your message
I think it's been it's a very powerful
film and we thank you for
that thank you
so oh well I mean if you uh you know I
think in some way
uh the the phenomena of nepales going to
the gulf to work is understandable uh
because they there's not enough
jobs and while while the gurka
recruitment uh especially now uh the
fellows who join the British gurkas are
not necessarily from poor
families uh for for you know decades it
was uh uh poor people from The
Hills uh many of who actually swear that
this was the opening the the opening of
their minds and this was the chance this
was what gave them the world the ability
to see the world
this is in relation to the debate about
Recruitment and not uh it's I think very
complex but in in this case yeah I mean
it's it's uh you know uh I think there
are some poor people but there are quite
a lot of well-off
uh applicants one of them who failed uh
I I saw in Amsterdam he was studying
medicine so uh so you know I mean I
think in the sort of compulsion to go
abroad this is one route because uh you
put in a few years and uh if you get in
after 4 and a half years uh well firstly
the salaries at PTY with the British
soldier uh after four and a half years
you can retire and uh leave the Army and
actually get a second career a training
in a second
career so uh yeah I mean you know and
and the numbers right now for British
gar recruitment is down to about 100 a
year so in a way you know uh in terms of
the debate
in a way it's it's it's so it's so few
that uh I don't think it's such a big
debate uh but in terms of people going
to the gulf there's 2 to three million
young nepalis in the gulf and
Malaysia and uh I think it's a class
phenomena is because most of Katmandu
would be indignant at the fact that
these people are going and I think
uh you know they just have to look a
little harder to see why people go
actually and it's more middle class
upper class sentimentalism I feel uh I
mean there there are lots of
quantitative uh sort of actual reasons
why there might be some you know like
there's a shortage of plumbers and
people say look they could have been
here but I think the point is people I
think act fairly rationally in deciding
to go it's necessity and uh
uh if if Le just looked at
the salary kind of scheme back in Nepal
then they would actually understand why
people go to get maybe 20,000 rupees a
month it's not easy to earn 20,000
rupees a month and the same for Mains
people say oh our women shouldn't go but
the maids get 15,000 rupees a month I
don't say that's a good thing but I
think people have to ask themselves and
look at the society I don't blame any
class but the fact is people you know
get uh a fraction of that so there's I
feel that uh on the whole it's fairly
rational why people are going in terms
of their you know where they are and
looking at opportunities to the left and
right and and then making that decision
because they know for sure all the
horror stories that are
happening so I mean I rambled on about
the gulf workers but that's I also
worked on three films about nepales who
good on the gulf so
yeah so thank you very much that was a
beautiful and Powerful film I don't know
this is not exactly a question but just
a request for you to comment on uh at
one point early in the film The Claim is
made that um that success or failure is
completely independent of the cast of
the applicants and then you have that
one little scene at the end where
someone's gotten in and the the giros
who are already in you know are sort of
expressing surprise at oh you you got in
and wonder if you could just comment
more about that well I mean as far as I
could see you know as you see the the
way of filming was uh uh you know
filming as a way of research in direct
Cinema is called in America and uh I
didn't do a lot of research I I read a
little bit uh I didn't really know a
hell of a lot about it and the point is
what do we Capt on the camera is is is
what we get right so from what I could
see I didn't really see you know any
blatant uh uh have any suspicion for you
know foul play as it were but as you as
you saw in the film it probably does
happen and maybe it was a much more
pervasive phenomena earlier on and maybe
that's also part of the reason why I was
allowed in because maybe they felt that
in the in the bizaar the the perception
is that it's all rigged up and maybe
they thought you know it's time to let
people know what happens so uh yeah as
far as I know I mean there there were
people from the T who were in now
whether in this there's a lot of tests
and whether the markings are obviously
there's a degree of subjectivity I'm I'm
not actually you know sort of defending
the or you know asserting that it's
total fair but it it appeared like that
to
me two final
questions
all that was a beautiful film thank you
very much I have a question about
something that's sort of outside the
frame that was referenced a few times uh
seems there's an interesting parallel
between the Manpower agencies and the
training programs that they kept
referencing you were talking about class
and now certain certain um apart from
cast about how certain people have a
certain class tend to go out for this
and certain people of a certain class
might have the resources to prepare for
it using one of these programs as
reference
so could you talk a little bit more
about that well I mean it's it's what I
know is what's there uh I think it's a
big it's a really tough contest and
actually the the it's really a big deal
for these young fellows who are applying
because some of them have been trying
for three or four times that means four
years and uh and you know they've
actually sort of inducted the gurka
ideology they've already become gurkas
except the in so it's a really hugely
I've heard of many cases of young people
being devastated and traumatized by this
for for
years uh so you know they use all the
means they can to go to training for
three or four weeks and but it's a tough
test I mean you saw the the when they
were getting you know their timings read
it was like
milliseconds uh you know so it's very
tough and I think in fact many of them
some of the British officers said all
the 500 who were in the final selection
could have actually you know fully
qualified but it's just that there were
so few birs does that answer the
question
or the flame is really wonderful uh but
I don't know how to uh put my question
in oh but uh I heard let me put my
question in a plain language um I heard
you know free fa the free fair and
transparent three or four times
um and it was was it needed or because
British Embassy gave you permission or
whether they asked
you you know put these things in ODS and
because I have heard many stories about
you know uh discrimination some cast are
faor not others um and also uh you know
after
recruitment uh British I I don't think
British officer but in the British uh
camps you
know uh those candidates who passed um
the you know taste they are forced to
you know adopt Hindu religion and other
sort of uh things and what's are your
thoughts on these matters yeah the
reason why I put it in uh is because I
think uh
uh in this setting I mean when you for
me the archetypal reason why someone
goes to war is to fight for the for the
for the soil for the motherland and
they're not doing that
obviously and so therefore in the vacuum
I think institution creates an
ideology so in the place of like you
have to go and fight and you know give
up your blood uh maybe these values come
in as the dominant ideological points
are this is a
fair you know trans trans arent uh
institutions whereas outside in Nepal
outside the gates of the camp uh po Camp
it's not uh the water is portable you
can drink water from any of the TAPS in
the camp whereas outside you cannot
don't make a noise in here don't make
Hala because this is non Nepal this is
an island so this is the sense that I
wanted to uh was my intention because I
mean you know uh it's not to back up my
earlier observations that maybe this
Fair uh it was with irony in a way right
so uh yeah and and iron further
ironically I mean the young fellow who
sings the song sings a song about the
mother land so you know there are I mean
I think you have to make sense of that I
think I I feel that people have emotions
and you know where they choose to be the
what they choose to be the repository of
the emotions is you know you you you
know sometimes you find yourself singing
a a uh a totally uh you know kit pop
song but actually your emotion is not
kid right so I mean that's the way I see
it k um I don't often run out of words
but I run out so thank
you and uh thanks for making the film
let's have dinner thank you very much
thank you